tennis star serena williams was walking
by a local tennis court last week when
she decided to surprise some casual
tennis players who were there practicing
okay totally
just a nice spur the moment act the
whole thing was caught on video and it
quickly went viral check it out i think
they are in the middle of cleaning out
points this is sweet moment she
surprised them I bring this up for a
reason Andy I hear something similar
actually happened to you recently it
actually did I was out for a walk out
here on the Warner Brothers lot and I
had an experience very similar to
Serena's and I got it on videos to take
a look okay there's some guys over there
working out I think I'm gonna go on
court and give them a little surprise we
got a great show tonight whether we do
or not a lot of times you really gotta
lie
the lecterns gonna tell you where it
wants to go oh yeah all you have to do
is listen oh yeah this guy knows what
he's doing yep there you go and that's
it that's it you got it yeah you might
think this guy isn't prepared but I can
tell that I'm looking at a pro cuz oh
yeah there it is meet you there serving
lunch over the Big Bang Theory so I got
a drop-by proof
you
you